da gibt es keine antwort für alle ich
glaube dass wir ein ganz gutes
verständnis von risiko haben und wir
haben ein evolutionär gut gewachsen ist
vermögen ein risiko einzuschätzen
wir können aber sehr schlecht mit angst
umgehen deswegen bin ich dafür alles zu
tun die angst heraus zu nehmen aus dem
alltag und zu einer vernünftigen einem
vernünftigen risikomanagement zu kommen
sagt man beispiel meine mutter gewohnt
in der nähe von uns ist 76 jahre alt und
hat für sich entschieden es ist eine
erwachsene frau im vollbesitz ihrer
kräfte
das risiko zu tragen ihre enkel zu sehen
und wenn jetzt jemand kenne und dass das
verbieten würde dann würde uns das auf
den magen schlagen und dass das haben
wir selbst entschieden und wir wissen
was wir tun und schützen uns natürlich
wie alle anderen menschen wer will schon
krank werden so genutzt nochmal kurz
zurückgegeben würden sie das der
großmutter verbieten als politiker im
herbst wenn die zahlen hoch gehen dass
sie ihre enkel ich glaube wir haben ihm
früh lernen müssen in mir geht es
jedenfalls so aus vielen persönlichen
bekanntschaften wir haben da zum teil
jedenfalls die isolation übertrieben man
wir dürfen ihn nicht so weit gehen dass
menschen dann letztendlich jede sozialen
kontakt beraubt werden weil sie in einem
pflegeheim in praktisch eine totale
isolation gebracht werden wir müssen ein
mindestmaß an menschlichen kontakten
auch in solchen situationen
aufrechterhalten